let's say that we have a function f of x
and it is equal to
negative 4
times the cube root
times the cube root of x and what we
want to do is we want to evaluate the
derivative of our function when x is
equal to 8. so see if you can figure
this out
all right now this might look foreign to
you might say well i've never taken a
derivative of a cube root before but as
we'll see we can actually just apply the
power rule here because this function
can be rewritten as so f of x can be
rewritten as negative four the cube root
of x is the same thing as x to the one
third power and now it might be a little
bit clearer that we can apply the power
rule we could take this one-third
multiply it by this coefficient negative
four so we have negative four times
one-third and you have times x
to the
one-third we just decrement that
exponent two that's the different shade
of blue to the
one-third
minus one power this is the derivative
so f prime of x is equal to that and so
now we just have to simplify this is
equal to
negative four thirds
times x
one third minus one is negative two
thirds power and so if we wanna evaluate
f prime of eight
f prime of eight is equal to negative
four thirds times eight
to the
negative
two thirds power
well that's the same thing as negative
four thirds
times eight
eight
to the one third and then raise that to
the negative two power i'm just using
exponent properties here this looks
completely unfamiliar how i got from
that to that i encourage you to review
exponent properties on khan academy well
8 to the 1 3 that is just 2.
so this is just 2
and then 2 to the negative 2 power
remember let me just take some steps
here it's a good review this is equal to
negative four thirds
times two to the negative two is the
same thing
as one over two to the two
these two things are equivalent that and
that
one over two to the 2 is the same thing
as 2 to the negative 2. so this is 1
over 4
and so this is going to simplify to
negative 1 over 3 is equal to negative
over
3 and we are done